[Music]
everything has become so political our
running shoes political our chicken
sandwiches political our sitcoms politic
every single thing
and people they want one little break
just one
not maybe you watch some football maybe
oh the olympics wouldn't that be nice
and no they take that away from us too
the nfl tells us that it's now
transgender lesbian and gay at the
olympics you've got the athletes
at least at the trials turning away
disrespecting the flag they just won't
give it to us
and since i'm not exactly the world's
expert on sports thankfully we have a
great expert on sports jason whitlock
former espn writer former fox sports
contributor now a man you've seen him
everywhere and now he's with the blaze
jason is going to
explain to me is it all over for sports
have the woksters just taken it forever
and and uh we've just got to move on or
is there some hope i don't think there's
any hope michael to be honest with you
and i'm someone who has never voted i've
always tried to avoid any type of
political identity
and you know i grew up an athlete i've
always been a passionate sports fan i
went to college on a football
scholarship sports was my little oasis
away from all
the political division and the political
hypocrisy that i love to try to kind of
avoid and now it's front and center in
the sports world
and quite frankly i blame china i i i
really do
i think that nike
is
so hyper concerned and focused
on increa in improving its relationship
with china and nike is the most powerful
force in american sports more powerful
than the nfl
more powerful than major league baseball
more powerful than the nba
and so i think through nike's
uh relationship and trying to improve
its relationship with china
they've made american sports very
political
and and a place to express anti-american
sentiment the ceo of nike infamously i
wouldn't say famously infamously just
came out and said that nike is a brand
of china and for china which i think
would be a surprise to a lot of nike
customers around the world and certainly
to a lot of american sports teams that
have partnerships with nike so
when did this begin and what what does
it mean for the relationship of
americans to their own sports teams john
donahoe the ceo of nike uh said that a
couple of weeks ago and in that same
conversation with wall street analysts
he talked about how
this has been
nike's plan and strategy for 40 years
nike founder phil knight
hatched the plan of taking nike
international started working on its
relationship with china
china has 1.4 billion potential
consumers
america has 330 million
and so
nike went from a great american success
story
uh
where they toppled all the other shoe
brands here in america and then they set
their sights on global domination and
that meant going to china
and and conquering that marketplace and
those 1.4 billion uh potential consumers
and so this has been 40 years in the
making and and i try to explain to
people michael that the nba the national
basketball association
its purpose is to market
tennis shoes gym shoes nike apparel
the nba is an 8 billion a year business
nike is a 40 to 50 billion a year
business
nike runs the nba
the nba is the marketing arm of nike and
so both nike and the nba have pursued
the international market and the global
market far more than they have
domest a domestic audience that's the
biggest difference or had been the
biggest difference between the nba and
the nfl but now you even see the nfl
caught up in
trying to please the woke crowd and
hopping on board with
nike and and their the anti-american
sentiment they're spreading through
colin kaepernick and lebron james
this parallels a major political
conversation that's going on right now
which is that for the past 20 or 30
years or so republicans have shield for
corporations that hate their guts and
that want to sort of undo the
traditional american way of life and and
what some republicans have said is well
look it's a free company it's a private
company and if they want to turn their
massive power on constantly denigrating
america why that's just the free market
at least we've got gdp ticking up a
little bit it seems to me historically
sports games have always had a patriotic
aspect to them they've all you know the
games are always about the community the
state the country the people and now
that's being divorced how long can that
last
or are people just going to tune out i'm
not sure
if it matters whether people tune out
we have flooded
our economy with so much money
there are no consequences for failure it
does your audience your tv ratings don't
matter
we're paying for agenda and narrative
and so as long as the nba the nfl stay
on message
the television networks espn fox cbs
they're going to cut enormous checks
and it doesn't matter that their market
share strengths here in america
our global corporations are paying for
narrative
arc and agenda and the agenda with a lot
of these corporations to me michael is
they prefer
the communists the chinese communist
party's way of doing
business
over the way we do in america elites
prefer communism
over democracy and capitalism
that's what i think people are going to
have to come to grips with
is that
the working class the common man has
been completely sold out
and the elites are going to put are
trying to impose
a system that's more like china
they can do business that way it doesn't
hurt the elites they're still going to
make their money they're going to be
treated well
in a communist society that really
if we think we favor
elites
uh wait till you people get a real taste
of communism and how they favor elites
and
really oppress the working class you
know i think it was charles munger
warren buffett's business partner but it
was it was one of those types if it
wasn't him one of these masters of the
universe who said that he didn't exactly
want china's political system but he did
want their economic system that it was
kind of easy to do business with them
and it might be nice to do business that
way over here and you you have seen this
very pro-china move not just in sports
but hollywood also infamously has sold
its soul to china you saw this in the
top gun remake all of a sudden
references to taiwan started to
disappear all of a sudden anything that
might upset the chinese communist party
starts to disappear because he who pays
the piper calls the tune well i get it
if i were the ceo of nike and i had no
sense of loyalty to my country then i i
probably would pursue that strategy too
if i were the head of a hollywood studio
and again had no loyalty to my own
country i'd probably pursue that
strategy too
is there any way for we for us as
americans to stop them from doing this
or are we just going to sell out our
sports and our culture to the highest
bidder i i do think we're going to have
to have an economic response
and and and again i'm not even sure if
that will matter to nike
or some of these other global
corporations but
if we could empower
some corporations that were
hyper-focused and
this will sound
comical when i when i say it but
about a month ago when i really started
thinking about this
i i went on the my pillow website
and bought a bunch of mike lindell my
pillow stuff
just to support a business
that manufactures its products here in
america
and
has a passion and a patriotism for
america
we're gonna have to start doing that
we're gonna have to start and and and i
hate to say it but it's just like i just
bought
a new car new mercedes and i kind of
regret it i should have bought an
america i should have bought an
american-made car but we're gonna have
to start really disciplining ourselves
and making wiser economic choices and
invest in companies that actually
believe in american freedom
there's i i don't think there's a lot of
the american public
that doesn't fully understand
what we're sacrificing
uh by allowing foreign interests to
manipulate our corporations and our
culture
we're gonna end up sacrificing the
freedoms that made this country great
and for those of us that are black the
freedoms
that
allowed us to be a part of american
freedom
uh if we were in if our country keeps
moving this direction of china
the political dissent
that
made black americans free will no longer
be available to us
we have to
and that's why what the daily wire is
doing what the blaze is doing
we're trying to educate people about
what's really going on and what the
ramifications are and and because
corporate media so beholden to the big
global corporations
they can't tell these kind of truths i
totally agree with that and all i will
say on that point jason is if you do
feel so bad and the guilt gets to you so
much i am willing to take the mercedes
off your hand you can it's fine i will
i appreciate it yes any time now what i
what i do want to know is
beyond the corporate level this actually
makes a lot of sense and i hadn't really
thought of it this way that
nike and a handful of other players but
really nike is is controlling so much of
this conversation and narrative
what what do the players really believe
are they just dopes or they are they
just kind of been brainwashed are they
cynically going along with this or some
of them self-censoring i'm reminded of
that gal gwen something or other the
hammer thrower from the olympic trials a
few weeks ago gwen yes and she
she said that she finds the national
anthem offensive she thinks it's a setup
that she's got to respect the
star-spangled banner she wants to
represent the united states on the
olympic team but she doesn't want to
stand up and put her hand over her heart
and respect the flag she seems to really
believe it i think her explanation was
nuts but it seemed seemed sincere at
least so what is it are the athletes
are they secret you know patriots and
they're just going along for the sake of
the corporations or have they really
bought into this stuff
i used to be an athlete
i went to school on a division one
football scholarship
i have respect for athletes
but
when most of your life and free time
are dedicated to developing your
physical attributes
i don't then turn to them at all these
are some of the greatest intellectual
minds in america i don't expect them to
understand i do expect them to be caught
up
in the culture that's being promoted and
so many of them are addicted to social
media and twitter and their phones
and their brains have been hacked
like all of us they're not alone all of
us have this phone addiction social
media app addiction
they're young
and they want to be popular they want to
be with the in crowd they want to make
money and so
and and and so gwen berry i get it she
just wants to make some money and be
relevant
he throws the hammer no one no one's
watching that event and she's not going
to win it yeah well how can she be
popular how could she be real oh
that's right the national anthem bugs me
i don't respect the flag they got
pictures of her
waving the flag and being patriotic it's
all it's a gimmick it's people young
people love attention
and so
there's some of that when it comes to
the professional athletes at the nba nfl
level
look particularly in the nba they have
they get paid so much money lebron james
makes far more money from nike than he
does the nba yeah and that's true of a
lot of the basketball players they make
more money from their shoe companies
than the nba and so they're just doing
what's in their financial best interest
as explained to them by their handlers
and the shoe companies and whatnot and
so just follow the money as it relates
to a lot of the athletes colin
kaepernick he figured out
there's more money in being a martyr and
a symbol than actually playing football
at the level he was playing
uh and so
i i just
my expectations for athletes are
they're gonna train hard be in shape
entertain us
they're not
political leaders they're not thought
leaders
if i were as talented as lebron james
i'd probably speak english as brutally
as he does
and i would probably think a lot of the
dumb stuff that he thinks
because if i were that i'd be so washed
in money and women i wouldn't have time
to read a book
i think that's that's pretty fair i
think that's probably true for a lot of
us and and lebron i mean he's kind of at
the forefront of this he said that a
black man in america can't walk outside
the door without being chased down by
racist whites and i think you know
lebron you're looking pretty good you're
looking healthy you seem to have a
pretty stable life here i even because i
know so little about professional sports
i just don't really follow a ton a
fellow baseball to some degree although
the mlb drove me so crazy the last two
years i tried to tune it out but when i
heard about the kaepernick story when it
first came up i thought
oh gosh i guess this guy must be
one of the great quarterbacks of our age
you know he must be one of the real top
athletes and but he's giving it up for
him no he's not he's this kind of middle
of the pack guy who figured out how to
make a buck and i guess more power to
him because he's doing better than most
of the other people who are still
throwing a football not only middle of
the pack but just
a bad attitude not an attitude that's
going to help your team win games
and be a you know again when you're
playing quarterback in the
nfl the on-field performance matters the
most but there are other things
leadership being the face of the
franchise almost like you're the mayor
of a city
and colin kaepernick didn't have any of
those things he had no interest in any
of those things he liked to build up his
biceps and his abs and take pictures
shirtless and put on beats headphones
and make money doing that
and and it sounds like i'm just beating
him up
i'm telling you if i had his kind of
talent at the age he was 28 29 30 years
old i'd be doing and thinking the same
thing
you know unfortunately i'm an overweight
50 year old and so i have to read books
and
newspapers and
i have to acquire information to make
money
so i think a little differently than
kaepernick i think that that's a curse
it is i believe it or not i never got
the call from the new york giants i was
waiting by my phone for many years
now
you know you've really helped me think
through this because i was looking i
said what is it about the woke ideology
maybe in the colleges when they were
playing college ball no i mean there is
there
is a real system of sticks and carrots
here and real economic incentives to be
to be doing this kind of thing is there
any hope
uh to to change that economic incentive
structure that seems to be turning this
this last institution that we had you
know the conservatives basically had
sports and the military both have gone
woke in the last six months and sports
was a little bit earlier than that so
that's kind of depressing you know is
there any way to reorder the incentives
be it at the level of the ncaa be it at
the level of the the professional
leagues or are we are we basically just
going to see them chasing dollars all
the way to beijing for the near future
look
um
america
hasn't always been driven by
or influenced by sports
and passion for sports they're you know
professional sports came along
130 40 years ago for the most part i i
think
and so
i think what is going to happen if we
have a chance
is that
those of us and i don't know your
religious beliefs i'll just speak about
mine those of us
uh with passionate religious beliefs
followers of jesus christ
we may have to abandon our love of
sports
and
we may have to
at some point stand up and remake
america where we de-emphasize
sports
and throwing all this money and
adulation
at guys who are ungrateful and
unappreciative
is a huge mistake they have way too much
influence over our culture
and so
uh you know there are we're in a
legitimate serious
critical culture war
and so they're a thing all of this stuff
in the coach from the music industry to
hollywood the sports
they're all gonna have to be remade
again or we'll just continue
on our path of destruction
and be the modern day sodom and gomorrah
and we know how that end
i love this take because what you're
saying and i know this is shocking to so
many people today is
you can't have everything you know the
nfl just said yeah football is gay
lesbian train football is everything i
said well it's not everything it's not
baseball it's not basketball it's not
the color
orange it's not the number seven you
know it's it is a
thing within limits because everything
has limits here and
for for christians we need to remember
the blood of the martyrs is the seed of
the church christians have been called
upon in history to do far more difficult
things than turn off the nfl you know
people might love their sports but there
are more important things in this world
i also have a bit of an advantage
because i never particularly cared for
the nfl but you're right i mean when
these when these companies are spitting
in the face of your values doing so much
to undermine your culture
at a certain point no matter how much
you like watching the game you might
just have to turn it off and that's part
of what i've as a sports journalist long
time and sports being a big part of my
brand
the the deal i've made with myself is
i'm gonna cover
sports honestly i'm not
i i'm not going to
god up
uh celebrate
people who don't espouse any of the
values that i believe in
and
so people oh man you're hypercritical of
lebron james and some of these other
woke athletes
yeah i'm like yeah i am
they're not
protecting defending
promoting the values that i believe in
they're promoting a secular godless
marxist worldview
they may not know it but i'm going to
point it out to them and point it out to
their fans and i'm going to do that for
the rest of my career until we get it
and understand it here in america this
is dangerous
this whole reimagining remaking
retelling of history that the
african-american journey in america is
something that damns america
rather than
enlightens people that like wow
look at what can be accomplished in
america you can start at the very bottom
as slaves in america and our
judeo-christian values
allow you to change the system in a way
that will grant you your freedom and
standing here in this country the
african-american journey is a great
american
success come from behind story
we've allowed the new york times and
everybody else
the african-american journey proves that
america is evil and irredeemably racist
it's just not true
i totally totally agree with you jason i
am so
so glad to hear this perspective where
else
can people find at your perspective now
that you're at the blaze well you only
need to find me one place you can
fearless with jason whitlock the podcast
wherever podcasts are
uh shown and displayed you can we got a
youtube page youtube.com backslash
fearless with jason whitlock obviously
you can find us at blaze tv there's an
app
uh but i'm writing and doing a podcast
we just started on tuesday today i'm not
sure when this is airing uh
but we just started today with the daily
podcasting show i've been writing
columns now for about three weeks you
can get those at blaze.com eventually
there will be a fearless vertical on
blaze where you can get my writing and
some of the contributors
uh but we're gonna keep chopping wood
appreciate you having me on i love it
jason great to be with you go check out
fearless go follow jason whitlock jason
thanks for coming on
[Music]
[Music]
you